madame monsieur bonjour et bienvenue en
direct sur le plateau de la voix est
libre sur france 3 bourgogne aujourd'hui
nous allons nous intéresser à la réforme
du code du travail un code de 3800 neuf
pages pour sa version dalloz 2015 un
code souvent donc critiqué pour sa
complexité alors faut-il pour autant
l'alléger faut-il le simplifier nous
allons en débattre avec nos quatre
invités sandrine mourey bonjour vous
êtes la secrétaire général de la cgt en
côte d'or
pierre-antoine kern bonjour bonjour vous
êtes le président du medef de côte-d'or
et du medef de bourgogne
edouard guerrero bonjour ont gêné la
paire général de force ouvrière en côte
d'or il bat président de l'upe et à
bourgogne bonjourbonjour bea étant
l'union professionnelle artisanale alors
à la maison je vous rappelle que vous
pouvez poser directement vos questions à
nos invités via notre site internet
bogen point france 3 point fr et puis je
précise également que nous avions aussi
agité d'autres syndicats la cgt la cftc
la cgc qui ont une autre approche pour
le dire que celle de fo et de la cgt
mais que tous ces syndicats n'ont pas pu
répondre favorablement à notre
invitation
alors là ministre du travail devait
présenter mercredi les pistes retenues
pour simplifier le code du travail
finalement myriam el khomri rendra sa
copie à manuel valls mercredi prochain
le 4 novembre avec un objectif on peut
dire ambitieux à savoir refonder le
modèle social un petit tour de table sur
sur cet objectif c'est une bonne idée
pierre-antoine cannes c'est une priorité
c'est une nécessité
la refonte du dialogue social alors du
dialogue social et du droit du travail
on en parlera j'imagine tout à l'heure
oui parce que on sait que les réformes
qui fonctionne dans ce pays sont des
réformes qui associe les partenaires
sociaux donc il faut évidemment
multiplier les accords et arriver à
réformer ce pays pour être plus
compétitif je rappelle quand même que le
contexte c'est quoi c'est un pays qui
aujourd'hui souffrent de rigidité de
trop de normes et il faut aujourd'hui
arrivé à libérer les entreprises pour
qu'elles soient compétitives dont la
rigidité puis on dit aussi que le
dialogue social est souvent compliqué en
france est ce que c'est un constat que
vous partager son amour est vous
moi je vais déjà répondre à votre
première question c'est à dire que
faut-il revoir effectivement le code du
travail nous pour la cgt on dit oui
effectivement revoir le code du travail
parce que de plus en plus son regard des
de ces dernières années on voit que de
nombreuses mesures ont été prises pour
déroger à la loi donc au code du travail
donc il devient de plus en plus
complexes et de moins en moins
protecteurs pour les salariés
donc effectivement regard de la mutation
du salariat des nouveaux emplois du
télétravail du numérique des normes on
voit qui bouge entre le salarié et les
indépendants oui effectivement nous nous
sommes partants pour revoir le code du
travail mais pour qu'il soit plus
protecteurs pour les salariés pour un
ensemble plus grand du nombre de
salariés ligne et l'ensemble en prenant
en compte l'ensemble des mutations du
travail j'imagine que vous êtes aussi
favorable à une réforme du code du
travail
alors vous qui représentez les petites
entreprises à l'artisanat notamment
il existe le dialogue social dans ces
petites entreprises il fonctionne alors
le dialogue social dans les petites
entreprises il existe et fonctionne on a
mis en place il ya quelques années des
commissions paritaires régionales
interprofessionnelle dans l'artisanat et
je peux vous dire que je peux même
prendre à témoin
edouard gayraud puisqu'il a il a fait
partie de la cpi à un moment donné je
peux vous dire que ça fonctionne et ça
fonctionne très bien
la cpr il ya deux bourgogne a produit
des choses on a notamment un livret
d'accueil qui va tout prochainement
sortir à destination des salariés des
d'artisanat en associant les chefs
d'entreprise pour un dialogue encore
plus étayée et encore plus argumentée
entre le salarié et le nouveau enfin le
nouvel embauché et le chef d'entreprise
et puis nous venons de sortir au mois de
mai au mois de mai lé fruit d'un long
travail
ce qu'on pourrait appeler un comité
d'entreprise à destination des salariés
et des artisans pour je dirais compléter
un panel d'avantagés d'offres pour les
salariés d'artisanat sur la question du
code du travail
j'ai quand même bien évidemment que je
suis tout à fait favorable à ce que on
se penche sur le le code du travail qui
vous l'avez rappelé beaucoup trop
complexe un petit peu de retour en
arrière en 74
on avait très peu de chômage n'avait un
code du travail qui pesait 300 g
aujourd'hui on est à plus d'un kilo
katsa s'est alourdi au même rythme que
le pourcentage du chômage je veux pas y
voir là un lien de cause à effet mais on
peut s'interroger quand même aujourd'hui
dans la situation de chômage de ce pays
s'il n'y a pas moyen en retouchant
certaines choses de fluidifier un peu le
les rapports entre salariés et
entreprises alors essayé de développer
tout ça mais tout d'abord pour finir ce
tour de table et de larguer jean claude
mailly dit lui qu'il est donc favorable
au débat sur la négociation collective
mais en même temps est faux et contre la
réforme du code du travail si j'ai bien
compris
est-ce qu'on peut débattre sans réformer
derrière alors je jean-claude
effectivement cette exposition sujet
nous ne nous ne sommes pas
fondamentalement contre contraint une
discussion sur le code du travail à
condition qu'il ya des conditions à
condition qu'on ne réduisent pas les
droits des salariés
parce que ce que nous vois ce que nous
voyons poindre aujourd'hui quand même
dans toutes les discussions
c'est la version d'aéras rchid énorme
par exemple on pourra peut-être en
débattre après avoir été en avance en
drôme dans le débat nous nous avons
toujours été présents lorsqu'on nous a
de poser la question est ce qu'on nous a
concerté consulter le code du travail
est gentil codifié nous y avons
travaillé à un moment donné il ya des
choses qui ont été faites
le code du travail que peu évolué il
évolue d'ailleurs la jurisprudence le
fait évoluer naturellement le code du
travail
loris bar disais tout à l'heure que le
code du travail pesée 700 grammes ou
quatre cents ans 300 grammes et
maintenant il pèse 1 kg 4 vous avez dit
tout à l'heure qui faisait notre 3900
page mais c'est toujours pareil et 3900
page vous prenez le code de le code du
travail aujourd'hui a noté
alors évidemment ce code du travail il
est énorme il ya des annotations les
jurisprudences ya tous les textes tous
les textes dedans mais nous sommes bien
dans une société moderne
il me semble il faut des codifications
je dis toujours par exemple s'il n'est
pas le code de la route on aurait des
morts à tous les coins de rue il faut
bien ce que du travail il est nécessaire
pour protéger le salarié n'est pas remis
en cause derrière il est pas remis en
cause
excusez moi mais la version dernier
rachid est normal offrant de le mettre à
la poubelle ainsi que les conventions
collectives et goûter pour l'instant
pour l'instant nous c'est parce qu'il va
y avoir dans
codifié dans les applications que nous
propose pour l'heure je vous donne une
réponse à votre question sur le fait que
l'on soit inquiète c'est la lettre du
président du premier ministre à jean
denis combrexelle pour son rapport une
de ses frères juste précisé avoir fait
de ce compris que selanne a émis un
rapport qui est un peu la base des
stations pour la réforme club de ses
phrases qui nous qui nous qui légitimise
inquiétude c'est que les partenaires
sociaux ne sais si tu ne se saisissent
pas suffisamment des souplesses que la
loi leur donne pour déroger au cadre
réglementaire standard donc la lettre de
près du premier ministre c'est dire
voilà il ya un cadre il faut que les
partenaires sociaux dans le cadre du
dialogue social puisse s'emparer de
négociations pour pouvoir y déroger
c'est à dire pour faire du moins-disant
par rapport à la loi
c'est ça qui nous rend inquiet car le
président de la république qu'il nous
dise effectivement ça sera pas possible
mais la lettre de mission du premier
ministre à jean denis combrexelle c'est
ça on confirmait alors je n'ai pas lu
cette lettre mais ça devient enfin
effectivement de la version des
hiérarchie des normes cela il faut
comprendre que l'inversion de la
hiérarchie des normes c'est à dire qu'on
peut négocier
dans le public on explique qu'il ya le
code du travail c'est la loi donc pour
nous et dans le cas de notre de notre
pays la loi doté de gare en gare en
pardon de l'intérêt général
la protection de l'ensemble des salariés
avec un paquet de garantie pour tous les
salariés quel que soit leur entreprise
leur lieu de travail ou leur métier
c'est un paquet qui garantit le statut
un ensemble de droits pour les salariés
après secteur privé voilà du secteur
privé après vous avez des négociations
branche grands secteurs d'activité et
vous avez des négociations d'entreprise
pour le moment et encore on voit que ça
change pour le moment il y a un paquet
de loi qui garantit en plus à des
négociations de branche qui doivent être
supérieure à la loi qui devait qui
doivent améliorer les conditions et le
statut des salariés et après des
négociations d'entreprise qui doivent
encore améliorer mais tout en prenant la
spécificité des secteurs et les
entreprises
l'arrière sûr
archi d'énormes association
d'entreprises peuvent être les
négociations de branche et encore moins
bien que le code du travail ça vous est
favorable
oui absolument parce que ce qu'il veut
que l'amour est savoir ce qu'ils
existent jusqu'à présent c'est ce qui
nous garantit surtout un taux de chômage
deux fois supérieur à nos voisins qui
ont aujourd'hui des réglementations en
matière de droit du travail plus souple
que les nôtres et qui ont des taux de
chômage de l'ordre de 5% voire pour
certains de 3%
quand nous sommes toujours supérieure à
10% et que sommes souvent proches de 11%
donc je crois que aujourd'hui le modèle
tel qu'il existe est arrivé à sa fin 11
% de taux de chômage ce n'est pas
admissible
donc aujourd'hui il faut permettre aux
entreprises de pouvoir s'adapter nous
sommes dans des marchés où une
concurrence internationale d'une part
avec des concurrents qui eux mêmes
dispose de droits du travail beaucoup
plus souple que les nôtres d'autre part
nous avons des clients de plus en plus
exigeants qui nous demande de réagir de
plus en plus vite et pour cela il faut
donc que les entreprises puissent
s'adapter au plus vite et au plus près
de leur marché et ça ça suppose que
plutôt que d'avoir un cadre
réglementaire très important à part les
trois mille huit cents pages qui bloque
beaucoup d'initiatives il faut que la
loi définisse le minimum de deux choses
essentielles et que on laisse au plus
près d'entreprise les possibilités de
négocier c'est la vraie démocratie que
dans une petite entreprise mais
l'entreprise on puisse négocier avec ses
salariés des conditions différentes de
celles qui sont celles d'une entreprise
qui est à 300 kilomètres d'un concurrent
mais c'est une bonne chose de pouvoir
s'adapter à nos marchés
c'était essentiel avant de laisser les
rebelles se garer au jeu juste une
confirmation pour vous aussi monsieur
bah les le code du travail est un frein
à l'embauché comme on l'entend souvent
parce que c'est pas vraiment ce que dit
notamment le fmi
si j'ai bien lu ses perspectives 2015
dit finalement le code du travail les
règles du travail n'ont pas vraiment
d'incidence je crois sur sur la
productivité et la croissance alors est
ce que concrètement dans les entreprises
que c'est quand même un frein à la base
pour l'en bouche c'est le travail hors
de sa vous n'avez pas trahi vous en bout
en bout
il y aura en plus il n'y a pas de code
du travail ne sera pas plus que s'il y
en a sociale dit s'il ya des demandes
voulait dire des commandes ceci dit
quand même un fait que aujourd'hui ce
qui paralyse le plus et surtout dans les
très petites entreprises que je
représente
c'est d'abord l'insécurité quel liée à
l'évolution permanente des textes et du
code du travail en trop c'est le manque
de stabilité c'est le manque de
stabilité ça c'est sûr et puis pour
reprendre les questions vous évoquiez
tout à l'heure certes on est pour que
les choses évoluent par contre je suis
pas pour et nous ne sommes pas pour la
version de l'énorme chaque chose à sa
place et jeune femme nous ne sommes pas
pour non plus le fait que tout soit
renvoyée aux accords d'entreprises
puisque dans les très petites
entreprises
ça voudra dire ce serait très compliqué
mais c'est pas très compliqué c'est
juste impossible 1 et 2 et de ce fait ça
exclura de la possibilité d'accord 97 %
des entreprises de ce pays
alors je vais quand même le début le
dialogue social alors le dialogue social
nous sommes pour le dialogue social est
bien entendu ça n'échappe à personne
par contre ça dépend la méthode utilisée
parce que si on nous amène des textes
ficelé déjà à l'avancé
et puis qu'on nous dit voilà comment on
va faire il n'y a pas beaucoup de
possibilités de négociation alors ce
moment-là dialogue social est faussé
nous disons alors pour répondre à
monsieur caire le monsieur kern êtes
d'accord avec moi que les chômeurs c'est
quand même pas le code du travail qui a
produit un chien c'est vraiment une
activité comme un art gallery non à
l'austérité
le ré vérité de périers les décennies
aujourd'hui à créer des conditions d'une
croissance zéro parsemé la différence si
si vous aviez de l'activité vous
embauche auriez beaucoup plus facilement
non faut pas dire que cette code du
travail qui s'immerge dans beauce est
ici bien sûr qu est ce qui vous en
bouche d'embauché c'est laisser les
articles concernant les élections c'est
les articles concernant l'organisation
du code du contrat de travail qu'est ce
qu'il ya dans ce code du travail
on a mis des textes on écrit des textes
pour organiser les relations entre
employeurs et les salariés
alors on en a parmi des textes très
serrée où les mythes et là la croissance
parce que j'étais vous répondre
interviewé des chefs d'entreprise vous
verrez qu aujourd'hui le code du travail
est totalement anxiogène c'est à dire
que comment voulez vous qu'un chef
d'entreprise puissent connaître chaque
article d'un ouvrage qui fait trois
mille huit cents pages c'est juste
impossible il faut qu'aujourd'hui ce
code du travail soit totalement
simplifiée et surtout soit moins
anxiogène pour les chefs d'entreprise
clair qu'aujourd'hui il ya des
licenciements qui coûte des dépôts de
bilan en réalité moi j'ai été conseiller
prud'homme vous savez j'ai vu des
entreprises déposer le bilan
à l'occasion du sentiment par des
connaissances et monsieur à cause des
dommages intérêts en sus et les rassure
personne ne peut apprendre enfin on ne
monte pas d'apprendre de code du travail
par coeur de travail ses talents de
connaître celle là nous dit c'est un
outil pour défendre
enfin pour régler les relations entre
l'employeur et le salarié ni vous ni moi
ni sandrine ivoire ne vont apprendre le
code du travail par coeur il faut
laisser ça à des spécialistes cerveau
c'est pour régler les problématiques
qu'ils peuvent qui peuvent surgir
mais la nouvelle série j'ai l'habitude
vous avez beaucoup de difficultés pour
licencier les salariés aujourd'hui dans
les entreprises c'est sûr ah bon la
dares par en 2014
six cent cinquante cinq mille
suppressions d'emplois pas très dur de
licencier chiffres de la dares un pas de
la cgt et pour compléter avec avec eux
pour pourrait dois vous parler de la
complexité du code de travail
mais qu'est ce qui rajoute des pages au
code du travail c'est les multiples
dérogations justement qui ont été
incluses au code du travail sur le temps
de travail
on peut y déroger on peut travailler
plus regardez il ya une dernière une
dernière note d'un dernier une note de
la direccte qui permet aux salariés
notamment de l'agriculture des trains
jusqu'à 60 heures on voit on voit aussi
des dérogations sur le contrat de
travail contrat à temps partiel on voit
également des dérogations sur le repos
dominical
on voit également justement des
dérogations sur le dernier accord qui a
été signé par le medef sur les coûts
à temps partiel 24 heures où il ya de
multiples dérogations où on peut
travailler moins de 24 heures la
lourdeur du code du travail vient en
grande partie à toutes les dérogations
qui ont été ajoutés au code du travail
et si vous voulez monsieur quels jeux
vous propose à faire sauf un deal
travail et le code du travail un sur le
temps de travail voilà on va réduire le
code du travail
madoff fera sur le temps de travail le
temps de travail c'est 35 heures toute
heure supplémentaire sera majoré points
on ne peut pas idéaux déroger et là on
enlève 40 pages du code du travail
et là vous verrez que eh bien tout le
monde sera au courant de la législation
sur les tempes et vous pourriez mais
j'imagine que monsieur kahn pourrait
être d'accord si derrière il ya des
accords de branche ou désaccords
d'entreprises sidérurgiques non monsieur
caire ne vous des accords d'entreprise
et en même qui a beaucoup été interpellé
non mais je crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est
vrai beaucoup de dérogation qui font la
lourdeur de berger parce que précisément
ce code est mal fait et donc il faut
d'une part effectivement prévoir des
dérogations mais d'autre part c'est
toute la jurisprudence au city feghouli
scott faut pas l'oublier agir oui moi
qui ai l'expérience d'être avoir été
conseiller prud'homme
c'est excessivement difficile de juger
des affaires aujourd'hui c'est pour ça
que y ait beaucoup d'avocats qui se met
en piste pour éclairer le débat mais
c'est d'une complexité incroyable donc
comment voulez vous qu'un chef
d'entreprise parce que vous dites c'est
réservé aux spécialistes que du travail
mais pas du tout c'est ce qui régit la
relation de travail entre les salariés
le patron c'est juste l'essentiel donc
aujourd'hui un patron qui ne peut pas
comprendre comment ça fonctionne
vous parlez du code de la route si
demain on multiplie les signaux les
panneaux et qu'on n'y comprend plus rien
y aura beaucoup d'accidents et c'est ce
qui se passe dans le code du travail
donc aujourd'hui il faut simplifier et
donner de la liberté davantage de
liberté aux chefs d'entreprise
c'est cela qui permettra de relancer en
partie l'économie il faut d'autres
choses aussi baisser les prélèvements
obligatoires et c'est les deux grands
points qui permettront à l'économie
française de redémarrer et donc d'être
en mesure de financer un modèle social
correct à devrait revenir sur ce qu'elle
dit aussi le président de la république
lors de la conférence sociale du jeu
9 octobre il a rappelé les lignes jaunes
il affirmé que la réforme ne concernera
ni la durée légale dont vous parlez la
durée légale du travail ni le smic ni le
contrat de travail notamment le cdi
alors sur quoi en fait on encore
négocier ce que pose il ya de la
déception est ce que pour vous ça peut
être une forme de soulagement et de
soulagement si c'est réel exemple si on
peut idéologie exemple l'accord smart
dont tout le monde a parlé donc 35
heures là où il ya le point sur la durée
du travail c'est le déclenchement des
heures supplémentaires c'est dire que
pour le moment actuellement le
déclenchement des heures supplémentaires
c'est au delà de 35 et on voit bien
quelle multiples accords qui veulent y
déroger au regard des smart c'est on
vous propose d'être allé 39 heures et
vous serez payé en gros deux heures
gratton 1 2 heures de travail gratuit
eh bien nous ça nous inquiète et c'est
là le problème et on renverrait à des
accords d'entreprise sur lé
déclenchement des heures supplémentaires
là où ça nous inquiète c'est que en
faisant ça en multipliant ça en faisant
ça le cadre légal du travail en france
c'est que vous auriez des salariés
qu'ils seraient absolument pas protégé
qui n'aurait pas les mêmes droits
selon leur entreprise vous êtes dans une
petite entreprise est bien qui souvent
des fois est victime de la
sous-traitance et qui est victime du
désir état du donneur d'ordres par
exemple les marges de manoeuvre elles
sont pas grands dans cette entreprise un
le donneur d'ordres est dit voilà moi je
veux une commande at elle pris vous
débrouiller et bien les marges de
manoeuvre comment va s'opérer dialogue
social dans cette petite entreprise n'y
a pas de marge de manoeuvre dans une
tout dans une grande entreprise ou à
peut-être des organisations syndicales
et un rapport de forces plus ou
conséquent peut-être que les salariés
pourront s'organiser pour voir de
meilleurs droits
donc on voit que la dérogation à
l'entreprise va multiplier l'ensemble
des droits des salariés et surtout les
rendent très inégalitaire chaque salle a
ri n'aurait pas les mêmes droits selon
l'entreprise selon le lieu est selon le
rapport de forces qu'il a dans
l'entreprise c'est très inégalitaire et
je comprends pourquoi messieurs qu'anna
vrai bien obtenir à avoir avoir ça parce
que c'est bien évidemment rapport de
force de l'entreprise
et bah quand on procède notamment chez
les sous traitants
un dialogue social qui se résume à du
chantage à l'emploi et revoilà pour
pouvoir avoir la commande
le donneur d'ordres il nous donne que ça
donc c'est où vous travaillez plus où on
licencie 2000 personnes dialogue social
ne peut pas se résumer à ça et bah c'est
bien pour ça que le lieu de la
négociation doit être la branche est pas
l'entreprise parce que je l'aï dit tout
à l'heure si on ramène le lieu de
négociations dans l'entreprise a exclu
de la possibilité dialogue et la
possibilité d'accord 97 % des
entreprises françaises et 97 % des
salariés qui travaillent dans ces
entreprises
à partir du moment où le dialogue
s'instaure au niveau de la branche ça
préserve aussi les conditions d'une
concurrence entre les différentes
entreprises alors que si on renvoie des
accords d'entreprise on aura du dumping
d'une entreprise à l'autre
bien sûr et bien sûr c'est tout à fait
évident la position en partage en partie
la position bien entendu ce kern le
dialogue social dans les entend
certaines entreprises il est
déséquilibré
vous pouvez pas affirmer que le gaz
sociale il est tranquille dans les
entreprises il est déséquilibré dans
certaines entreprises
en plus le cas que tu viens de citer
c'est une entreprise où il n'y a aucune
difficulté financière c'est pour se
projeter dans l'avenir jusqu'à 2020 on
dit on va faire cet accord pour pouvoir
avoir des parts de marché etc
mais il n'ya même pas de difficulté dans
cette entreprise qu'est ce qu'on est en
train de déclencher si ce n'est que
aujourd'hui on sent qu'il ya un dogme
est derrière tout ça on sent qu'il ya un
dogme excusez moi on se souvient que on
sent bien que le medef aujourd'hui on a
des atouts de ce gouvernement
non mais que faire j'avais juste dans
l'urbanisme
on vous donne quand vous quand vous
écrivez quand vous décrétez que cette
entreprise smart elle ne rencontre pas
de difficultés mais qu'en savez vous
n'êtes pas au conseil d'administration
ça est passé maintenant b enfin attendez
c'est pas parce qu'il ya à dire en un
instant t qui va donner
là ça a été dit c'est quand même plus
compliqué que ça non m'a donné ce teddy
par qui a été dit non mais écoutez ce
que je crois qu'elle des chefs
d'entreprise sont pas des gens qui sont
des sadiques
ils sont pas là pour vouloir le plus
grand mal à leurs salariés c'est pas la
question est simplement il faut pouvoir
donner une plus grande liberté aux chefs
d'entreprise en matière d'ajustement sur
le plan d'aidé du recrutement et puis
éventuellement des licenciements si
c'est nécessaire
et puis permettre l'ajustement alors au
niveau des branches on est d'accord
active
bien sûr quand on peut le faire au
niveau des branches est une bonne chose
mais si à des cas particuliers à traiter
au niveau de l'entreprise il faut
pouvoir également le faire maintenant on
peut peut-être aborder les autres sujets
parce qu'il y avait quand même s'il
obéit à des normes au niveau européen
pourquoi ne pas adopter en france les
normes européennes enfin moi je pose la
question qu'est ce ça nous mais ça nous
mettrait je vous répondrai à équité se
fait déjà
non non c'est pas le cas mais si on
savait très bien les multiples deux
jours je n'hésitais les multiples
dérogations au temps de travail elles se
font la norme européenne ces 48 heures
et il y à des salariés actuels et sur ce
sol y ait des salariés et wiba faire
traîner intervient de temps calculé sur
ces semaines est regardée ya même yanhel
dans le ja même dans l'agriculture
jusqu'à 60 heures ici là sur les côtes
de beaune
les salariés travaillent jusqu'à 60
heures autorisation de la dir est alors
je connais pas mais vous savez les
multiples dérogations le temps de
travail des salariés en france
ses 39,9 heures c'est pas les chiffres
de la cgt si les chiffres de l'insee
alors on ne juge pas sûr qu'ils ne
travaillent que 35 heures il ya de
multiples dérogations je lui transmets
mon nom c'était plus que l'allemagne
pour l'ensemble des atp des équivalents
temps plein ou si on prend l'ensemble du
temps de travail et pour ce pour le
temps de travail les salariés qui sont
contraints des temps partiels imposés
mais ces salariés là et notamment ces
femmes dans la grande distribution
aimerait bien travailler plus elles mais
elles n'ont pas le choix parce que dans
la négociation quand ces salariés
veulent travailler plus on voir leurs
patrons mais dites donc moi j'ai un
contrat à 18 heures j'arrive pas à vivre
j'aimerais bien 13 jusqu'à 35 heures
elle pas trop leur dit quoi non non il
n'y a pas ni glacial possible ce qui se
passe il arrive bien travailler plus
donc c'est pas une histoire de dos m
donc la réalité il faut aujourd'hui
permettre aux entreprises d'être en plus
en capacité d'embauché d'arrivée des
systèmes vertu
ou entre 3 et 5% taux de chômage aurait
été c'est le salarié qui choisit son
entreprise c'est ce vers quoi on doit
tendre et tous les freins que vous
mettrez en bétonnant le droit du travail
en en faisant une image hinault avec
l'efficacité qu'on lui a connu pendant
la seconde guerre mondiale quand même
donc plus vous vous étonnerez le droit
du travail plus vous créerez de
conditions pour le que le chômage
progresse
il faut nous libérer
vous rajoutez à dire chefs d'entreprises
pour leur donner plus de libéral en vous
vous en avez des libertés monsieur k
flexibilité l'accord sur la fesci la
flexisécurité a abandonné qui a été
donné vous avez obtenu cet accord sur la
flexibilité laver je l'avais aujourd'hui
défendre à l'époque c'était le graal on
avait créé des milliers d'emplois
d'ailleurs votre présidence promener
avec un pin's un million un million
d'emplois créés ou est-ce qu'ils sont
liés à un million d'emplois créés la
flexibilité des conversions ce kern
vous savez combien il ya eu de rupture
conventionnelle signé options
conventionnelles c'est ce que ça veut
dire oui à plus de sessions tueur d'un
cdi
il ya plus d'un million 700 mille
ruptures conventionnelles qui ont été
signés ces démissions destruction ça
n'existe plus oui bon baron les
démissions ça n'existe plus et c'est pas
une omission est la rupture
conventionnelle sûr que si c'était des
missions sont des ruptures
conventionnelles aujourd'hui alors si
vous vous l'empathie peut créer une
rupture conventionnelle
moi j'appelle ça un peu conventionnelle
c'est comme ça que c'est codifié 1
million 700 mille
vous avez des possibilités quand même de
flexibilité dans cette année un million
si si cantat salariés via millions 500
mille cdi détruits depuis 2008 non je
connais vous me dites ah ben y'a pas de
flexibilité pas d'envoyer un de
licencier les gens ça s'est passé comme
c'est faux faut pas faire d'amalgamé
devant les ruptures conventionnelles
sont pas qu'à l'initiative des
employeurs bien sûr mais aussi un
million sept cent mille mais quand on
parle de sibérie p c'est aussi une façon
de quitter son entreprise poirier il
cédera forcément la volonté du patron
que de se séparer d 1 million 700 mille
employés concernés dire que la mise en
page et les efforts soient élevés ils
viennent s'il est validé pour qu'on les
aide à rédiger leur rupture
conventionnelle c'est pas la grande
majorité s'est pas à l'initiative du
salarié 1 c'est parce qu'à un moment
donné il
il ya une tension dans l'entreprise et
c'est une façon mais ce que je veux dire
par là monsieur clair ne sait pas que je
suis pas compris qu'on était signataire
à l'époque de cet accord concernant la
rupture conventionnelle
je dis qu'il ya possibilité pour vous
aujourd'hui de licencier parce que je
vous ai lu je vous ai lu à certains
moments dans certains journaux vous
disiez il vaut il faut il faut la
possibilité de lys entre deux licenciés
pour mieux embaucher vous avez dit que
vous avez ces possibilités là
aujourd'hui
vous avez ses possibilités et vous en
voulez encore plus non je vais vous
donner un exemple il suffit qu'il y ait
un début de contentieux entre un salarié
et l'employeur pour que de toute manière
il soit impossible de fonctionner avec
une rupture conventionnelle donc c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué que vous ne le
présente et je vous rappelle que j'ai vu
alors à l'époque encore pas trop de
requalification de ces ruptures
conventionnelles parce que j'ai quitté
le conseil de prud'hommes depuis
quelques années mais on voit bien que
dès qu'on instaure un nouveau dispositif
il est de toute manière de par la nature
même du droit français en capacité
d'être discutée et c'est ça qui
d'ailleurs nous pose problème c'est
quand même si on met en place des
dispositifs de toute manière on est dans
un système judiciaire qui fait que ça
peut être mis en cause par un juge donc
et voilà donc on est on est très très
contraint aujourd'hui dans notre ami ce
fonctionnaire le temps le temps de
travail et le temps passe vite
il va être bientôt millions va continuer
à cette discussion d'un seul instant
mais on va s'interrompre quelques
minutes pour jeter un coup d'oeil sur
l'actualité régionale de ce samedi midi
le flash est présenté aujourd'hui par
arnaud lefebvre et on se retrouve donc
juste après donc dans les cinq minutes a
tout de suite